greetings and peace welcome to the dean
shaw media host and
we have our special guest coming up who
was involved
in this new age kind of movement so we
want to get to know
some of the things that she was involved
in the meditation seems good why not
getting in touch with your spiritual
side seems good why not and then you get
into this energy and the crystal balls
and the list goes on so let's go get
more familiar with this new age movement
and then what brought her to now the way
of life that she's upon that she's on
the dean's show with my next
guest
assalamu
so tell us a little about this new age
a movement now it's like
a new religion almost
it is it's a huge um
way of life for a lot of people
um
it's
you don't realize the darkness of it
until you really get into it um
it's such a smooth way in
um
what happened was i went
i was having a problem when i was in my
40s
with
going through car washes
which sounds funny but
my
friend at the time said we need to go
get past life regressed and i said well
gee that makes sense
not to anybody else but me
and so i went and this woman said
you're a very powerful healer you have a
powerful third eye you know all of the
so she kept putting me to more teachers
and more teachers and more teachers and
finally i ended up in the rocky mountain
mystery school in utah
channeling extraterrestrials
um they were teaching us about the
archangels and their wives
you know just
all this crazy stuff i was on that path
for five years
and then i
found an energy guru in england
and
she said
oh you know we have to start doing these
workshops together around the world and
so i
i said okay you know by that time i was
very hooked if you knew the story the
story is that
little by little i left
catholicism when i was 15 and then i did
buddhism and i did the kabbalah the
mystical side of it and this all led up
to me you know and then everybody i met
on that new age path said oh you're a
healer you're a toner you're this they
just it just pulled me along until i did
something so crazy but you know what
allah wanted that now i know that
so i this woman and i decided she said
we have to go to egypt
and i said okay now this is how i came
to islam
she said i have to go to egypt we have
to go to egypt
and
tone you know and do energy work there
which the workers there hate by the way
the muslims
um
so what happened was i left my
my home which was 2 400 square feet
i left my
job i had been a hairdresser
booked solid for a month in advance
i left my car i left everything i got a
backpack
in my 40s imagine that just left
everything
got a backpack
filled it with clothes
got a passport i didn't even have a
passport i've never been out of the
country
i fly to egypt she's supposed to meet me
there she does not meet me there
so
i'm in the airport i don't know the
language i don't know the culture i know
nothing and i'm scared to death
so i finally got to a hotel room and i
asked her what do i do next now this is
this is how allah sets things up for you
she said you have to go out to the
seraphim which is in sakata which is the
first step pyramid that they ever built
in um in egypt
um
and you have to tone in front of these
24 niches
and i was used to that from her so i
said okay so the next morning i got a
taxi driver who spoke english and he
took me
it's a beautiful drive to sakada
beautiful get out of the city and
there's a water buffalo and then it was
just beautiful
and then you get around the corner and
there's
the
the giza plains with gold sand and palm
trees
so i we pull up to the ticket office
and i say to the ticket office that i
want to get into the seraphim and they
said oh it's impossible we're renovating
it and i knew that if you just grease
some palms you could get in there
so um
they called over there was two very
young very handsome young men off to the
side
dressed in little you know suit you know
suit pants and shirts and they were i
found out later they were inspectors of
archaeology so the first one came over
and he said and i told him what i wanted
and he said that's impossible
the second one came over
leaned his face in the taxi i told him
what i wanted
and he
he was so amused with me
he became my husband three months later
this muslim man
three months later
so this is how allah works is eventually
he got me into the seraphim he got me
into all these other things and a week
later he proposed
and i did not go to egypt looking for
a husband at all but he was muslim
and he was so kind and i'd watch him go
around the streets and you know feed the
poor and he was so good with everyone
so
so that's
the new age path i was on was you know
you you had huge crystals you would
sleep with every night and
um there's a big community and so you
don't feel alone it's not like you're by
yourself
so that also was a very um
it was a pull it was a pull for five
years really i was in it so deep
and
how i got out of it is another story
uh so let's go let's back it up a little
bit let's just touch upon before you got
into the new age
movement
can you tell us
you were your parents were christian
let's just touch upon that briefly what
took you away from
christianity towards the new age
movement if you can just touch upon that
yes um well catholicism
i just remember as a young child being
kicked out of catechism because i asked
you many questions
i had a natural curiosity about it
because it didn't make sense
so when i was 15 i had a very large
family and
my father would go to the first mass my
mother would go to the last and we would
go to the middle ones so we take all the
little kids with us drop them off and go
to the restaurant eat come back pick
them up ask what the sermon was about
and go home
because we j it just made no sense it
just you know the trilogy made no sense
and i was not seeing
what i was being preached anywhere
i was not seeing it so i left and i
started getting into books about
reincarnation at a very young age and
that's what led me on that path
are you familiar with these names uh
uh
anton levay
yes
all right there's a there's a statement
many people make the connection because
now people kind of get turned off by
religion so now they're not filling the
void in their heart you know we all have
that fitra that innate nature nature
that god create us and to worship him
alone and not his creation so people now
go we see this happening so often that
now celebrities and just young people
and even some muslims are sad to say
they end up going just under the pretext
like you know because it's not cool to
be a part of a religion so they say
and then they jump into something that
actually ends up being another religion
so i want to share with you this quote
from anthony levay
you probably maybe came across it where
he's actually
saying that the new age let me say here
for himself he says new agers have
freely drawn all manner of satanic
materials adapting into their own
hypocritical purposes but in truth all
new age labeling is again trying to play
the devil's game without using his infer
no name
exactly
what do you what are your comments on
that and for those that know uh tell us
a little bit about anthony levite
i i don't know i've only heard the name
and i know that he leads the satanic
cult that's all i know i do know about
the new age path and the darkness
because
um
he's written the bible he i mean i'm
sorry he's written he's the founder of
the church of satan and the satan bible
what they have
exactly he's very yes he's
ahead of it
all i know is that
allah wanted something from me so he
allowed me to continue on that path
but once i learned about the jinn
and about shaytan
then everything fell into place that was
exactly what was happening these this
this one woman would
leave her body and allow some being to
come in and
she called he called himself metatron
and we would call him on the phone and
ask him questions he would get into
ourselves and it was just the most
bizarre thing
now that i see it i know how allah
protected me and i pray for those people
on that path because it's like a jinn
convention
you know they're just it's like what
it's like
convention it's like a gym convention
like a shriners convention where they
ride around in the cars that's what it's
like they're everywhere it's crazy wow
there's also someone else who's very
popular they say she's the the mother of
the new age movement uh helena
helena blevins
here's one of her some of her quotes
and many people who
have connected again the new age
movement
they don't realize that many of these
satanic rituals
like you're talking about they're in
this movement so let's just go over a
few of these here
this is one of the things her pretty
much praising
satan
yeah here's another one satan the enemy
of god is in reality the highest divine
spirit
uh you have her saying lucifer is divine
and terrestrial light the holy ghost of
satan at one uh and the same one at the
same time here's here's another quote
from her and the reason i'm quoting this
is because she is again one of the
people that many uh people who follow
this way of life
they look to her as one of the prophets
uh it is satan who is the god of our
planet and the only god this is in her
book
in volume 2.
yeah it's called
because
i didn't convert until i was 49 years
old
so i know the darkness
and i know the light now yeah there's
just no comparison there's just no
comparison
uh this is a professor of religious
studies from baylor university
commenting on this lady helena
talking about how she
uh was
the
well his her words
of modern recall thought and was either
the originator or the popul one who
popularized
many of these ideas and turns which have
a century later been assembled within
the new age movement so he's talking
about much of the stuff that we get in
the new age movement comes from
this
lady uh helena
because you know i've been out of the
new age movement obviously i've been
muslim for 20 years
and so i don't follow it but i'm not
surprised because if it was
hinting at darkness in 20 years ago
then it then shaitan has as you know has
you know come forward
quite a bit in this society
so it's a very sad thing it's a very sad
thing have you heard of this name
aleister crowley
that one i have yes i have heard of him
yes
yeah this is another one that uh here's
one of his quotes i was not content to
believe in personal devil and serve him
in the
ordinary sense of the world i wanted to
get hold of him personally and become
his chief of staff this is somebody
who is very popular in this movement now
this alistair crowsley and he's someone
that you can see
it's very interesting one of his one of
his quotes
and i'll i'll share it with you right
now it's very scary here
for the highest spiritual working one
must accordingly choose that victim
which contains the greatest and purest
force a male child of perfect innocence
and high intelligence is the most
satisfactory and suitable victim for
nearly all purpose of human sacrifice is
best this is very scary because if
someone whoever
knows about many of these occultist
groups and meetings and he's pretty much
uh glorifying sacrificing you know young
baby pure boys it's crazy
it is crazy and i thought i went through
some crazy stuff and i did
for five years but um that's beyond what
i
if it would have been
that
that i went to i wouldn't have gone to
it yeah but it was
the pull of the sweetness of it you know
to be that path is you know parallels
islam in a lot of ways the one i was on
and there was a sweetness about it the
ritual about it that i just loved so
when i became muslim i just jumped the
tracks and then found that
you know but there was a parallel a lot
of things paralleled
yeah when you mention like you you talk
about meditation we obviously have salah
prayer like
jesus prayed moses abraham last in
fundamental prophet muhammad
you know um
you know these uh connecting with the
spirit the spiritual so like it seems
like they catch you with some of these
things but then you know crystal balls
come into play fortune telling
you know connecting with the jinn like
you just said you know it's like a jinn
fest
right and the
you know the associating partners of god
almighty
yeah it's rampant um i meditated for
four hours a day before i became muslim
two in the morning and two at night
and i
i really um
lost
a lot of the the
trauma that i carried as a child so all
of that was you know kind of again i see
it as a huge plan from allah to bring me
to islam and i'm so grateful i mean who
else was going to leave their home
pack a bag
at 40 years old 40 some
and fly to egypt and the next morning
meet her muslim husband
yeah what is that i didn't become muslim
for about six months after that but and
i hit the wall lost 80 to 100 000
that energy guru i got was bilking me of
my money and i was building me of my
money and
so i i really lost almost everything but
i got islam so
what would you say made the most sense
in islam and for the not yet muslim
audience islam simply means to acquire
peace by submitting yourself just like
jesus did moses abraham the last
founding measure from muhammad to the
one and only created the heavens and
earth not worshiping his creation but
worshiping him alone so you say that
earlier
that
what your parents were upon that way of
life
this didn't make sense many people who
i've had on they struggle with the
trinity
and they struggle with a lot of these uh
these concepts uh
jesus dying for someone's sins so now
you come over to islam what made sense
about islam that had you
end up accepting it
on that new age path i
always had more questions than answers
that's what kept me seeking
is that i would go to the next level the
next level the next level because i
couldn't
fill that void
it everything that came to me i couldn't
feel that what i felt okay
but i couldn't fill that void and i kept
looking i mean imagine i was making you
know 70 000 a year as a hairdresser i
left that
to find a law
and so when i finally
saw my husband the way he was it made
perfect sense to me and then
once i got cleared out enough to accept
islam
in that next six months
then everything made sense
every question i ever had in my life for
anything made sense i was able to find
it in the quran i was able to you know
incorporate it into my life and there
was just this piece
i mean we have questions as in this
society if you look out there
we have questions about what's going on
well
we don't anymore i mean you know i've
written three volumes of islamic history
and the final volume
has the minor signs of the day of
judgment and a timeline about how they
came about so what i'm saying is that
you look you can look at the news now
and say oh that was predicted
that was prophesized
you know and it brings a piece because
you know
then this world can't be all there is
yeah that's amazing when you look at the
prophecies you look at the signs and the
quran the miracles
it's just impossible that a man prophet
muhammad peace and blessed be upon him
would who just coincidentally is
bringing the same message as jesus moses
you know
the message that goes with our innate
nature to just worship one and only one
god and be morally upright simple
message but then he backs it up with all
this evidence and it's just impossible
now that he was on point with so many
different things it's not like
nostradamus guessing 99
no and all 99 are wrong and one thing
it's just kind of maybe if you can take
a leap you can somehow connect it but
you don't have any of those things with
um but that's exactly the gin right they
now are given only bits and pieces
because the big fireball comes so if
somebody's channeling that they're only
going to get bits and pieces
yeah and that's what someone like
nostradamus you know so these people
aleister crousley you know these people
that we mentioned uh
levay and anton levay these people
obviously like you can see uh people who
are connect connecting with like uh
analyst crowds he said i want to be the
chief like the chief uh
worker for shaytan the devil on earth
and it was interesting how he died he
died on they say just doped up on drugs
you know
miserable a miserable existence
miserable life i will tell you there
were a few times
that the darkness got very very close to
me
and i didn't like it
i didn't like it
and um
mostly allah protected me through those
those years
but i did not like the darkness the feel
of it if you like that there's something
inside of you that's wrong
yeah i was uh
someone was sharing an experience that
he had
someone that i
talked to and he was telling me how he
got invited
to one of these events and it was kind
of like you had to
know someone who knew someone to kind of
get invited to this
um
ritual ceremony they were going to have
so
he went and it was like a group of
people and then they did some kind of uh
hallucinating some kind of drugs
and then they were calling out like
doing some kind of chanting and calling
out to some kind of spirits
and it was like you're saying it was
just very he said it was just very dark
you have to describe it it was just
and our that's not our fictional nature
that's what amazes me is that
our fits of nature is connect to allah
is to connect to the one god
and and there's no confusion then yes
there's just no confusion
i want to just share this point for the
muslim non-muslim audience when we say
allah jews and christians who are also
arabic speaking they use the word allah
allah just meaning the god the creator
of the heavens and the earth
so this is uh something that you can
relate to
now tell me this uh when you get asked
are you are you back in the states now
do you live in america oh yes we've been
here since well we came i brought my
muslim husband back into the states on
the first of september 2001
unless 10 days before
the big thing happened
so um yeah we were followed by the fbi
and all that kind of stuff that's okay
um
but yes we've been back in the states
for 20 years my husband is acclimated
here now and doing well
so when you get asked by family members
or at the grocery store or just
you know randomly have you ever been
asked or maybe you're talking about
islam and someone asked you like
a question about hijab you know how do
you like to answer that why are you
wearing hijab when so many women are
fighting for their freedom and now they
they look at hijab as a symbol of
oppression what do you say to that
freedom for what
i mean what really if you want to be
free from allah
that's one thing
what i say to them is that for 49 years
i was out there i was a hairdresser a
professional singer you know these kinds
of things i was just out there and
i don't think i was ever really
comfortable with it and then when i was
told i needed to cover the more i
covered the better i felt and when it
was explained to me that
you are a pearl in an oyster
and only your husband is allowed to see
what you've been showing people for 49
years now that made sense to me
and that
so that's what i tell people is that i'm
absolutely at peace with it and the
first thing i say is look i believe it's
a commandment in the quran
i believe that
i believe we're commanded to cover for
the right reasons because he knows us
better than we know ourselves you know
you see these women they start kind of
inching it back and a little bit of hair
showing and pretty soon they're putting
a little makeup on
pretty soon they're you know throwing
the jill bob off it allah knows best
allah knows best what we need and if you
are tied up in this lifetime this is
what you will do and if you are
hooked on the hereafter
this is what you would do
yeah we call it the uh some call it the
convertible hijab
the one you just described
that's right
may allah god almighty help all of us to
uh
go ahead and you know implement and love
the injunctions that are good for us
actually and help ward off uh things
that can harm us and if we can see that
coming out of love that allah loves us
and that's why he sent his guidance for
our for our betterment
tell me uh it's interesting that many
people when you make the comparison when
you look at
you know nuns when you look at those who
and christians should understand this
they're actually wearing the hijab and
then when you look at for instance mary
the mother of jesus from any picture
they have portrayed of her she's wearing
what you're wearing the hijab so you're
trying you're trying to imitate mary the
mother of jesus when when they find that
out like what do you i get people most
people are just stumped
well
i wouldn't want to tell you what my
mother said as a staunch catholic when
she asked me why i wear that thing
and i said
i said ma
the nuns cover
yes
and and she just she gave me a line that
i don't know if it's right to say it she
said well they're virgins and i went
okay i'm not going to have this
conversation with her anymore
you know so
it
they don't think of us as the same
i don't know
why but they don't think of us as the
same those they've always been revered
the nuns have always been revered
yeah
yeah when you go i'm sorry go ahead
no i'm just saying that
because we're not out there enough
speaking
about this beautiful dean
the media takes over
and so when they see me they see
oppression
and sometimes i look at them and i say
do you really do i look oppressed to you
you know i'm out there i'm doing all
that i need to do
no
yeah you're here uh in america now and
nobody can force you to where you're
wearing it out of your free will and
your love for god for the creator a lot
exactly exactly
yeah when
when a christian is asked say why do
nuns
wear this what they're wearing dressing
in such a modest
way in the hijab they usually say
because these are the best of the best
of us you know they've dedicated our
life to god but now if we take that same
answer and we say well these are the
best and the best of our women they've
dedicated their life to god why the
double standards that's the thing
well this is what
i just let it lie
because they're going to think what they
want to think until they think
differently
yeah and then you have places like
france for instance who are now pressing
muslim women from getting education
you know forced to possibly get arrested
if they
they want to have a hijab ban you know
you know we're very blessed here in
america we don't have that true i don't
know how i would handle it i do know
that i would stay covered and and i
would not
take that off for any government
so
tell us now as a muslim woman one who
submitted her will to the creator of the
heavens and earth again i just say this
always because so not a lot of people
who are tuning in for the first time so
they heard hear the term muslim or islam
and they have these preconceived notions
so i like to define the words so a
muslim is again someone who just submits
his or her will to god to the creator
that's what it means that concept has
always been there since the beginning
not worshipping the creation but the
creator so now that you're that you're
you're a muslim
uh can you can you tell us
what's your
connection to jesus now
that was
such a beautiful story you know
i
i
only knew him as
the god when i was younger and i didn't
think about him for a long long long
long time and it
kind of broke my heart
when i became muslim i realized i could
love him
more than the christians because
he was a beautiful prophet the word of
god i fell back in love with him you
talk we're talking about jesus yeah
we're talking about
about jesus and i just um
now when i read about his life i can put
it into context because before i had to
push him away because i had to push what
they were saying about him away
and um
for me it was lovely i mean really
i'm
my my first um
you know islamic history book is about
the 25 prophets in the quran and in
historical context
and when i was writing about him oh it
was just so lovely he's a really
gentle he was a really gentle human
being
yeah many people don't know that it's an
article of faith to believe and love
jesus not as a god or a literal
synagogue but as a mighty messenger who
was sent with the same message as
abraham to worship one and only one god
absolutely yeah thank you very much
thank you very much for sharing
some of the highlights of your story
loretta and god almighty allah continue
to bless you in your journey thank you
you too eddie for all you do subhanallah
thank you so much thank you ahead
and thank you guys for tuning in to the
dean show something that stood out at
the end is we're losing our youth
is so extremely important that we
understand some of these modern concepts
that are coming out
and many of these ways of life like this
whole new age philosophy and now
we've connected it like many people do
you know to when you uncover it the
roots of it is
is deeply embedded in many of these
satanic rituals and whatnot because the
way of truth is clear and she mentioned
beautifully you know the stories of the
prophets these were the men of truth
these were the men who brought
you the purpose of life men like abraham
who was a pure monotheist
jesus peace be upon him moses abraham
solomon all these men came with the same
message to worship the one and only
created the heavens and the earth
nothing is worthy of worship
except the one who created you and to be
morally upright and then you have the
last and final master sent to mankind
prophet muhammed peace and blessings be
upon them all
and then today we have the quran a
living miracle
testable that you can go ahead and if
you're sincere and you're asking the
creator that has the earth to guide you
and then you go ahead and put it to the
test read it you'll see like over one
point eight billion people have in the
world that it is indeed from the creator
of heavens and earth thank you for
tuning in we'll see you next time
subscribe if you haven't already
and connect with us here every week on
the dean's show peace be with you
assalamu alaikum